saber que el ministro del interior Denis
monasters que tiene
muchas funciones relacionadas con la
defensa del país Bajo su ministerio
ministerio está también la policía como
las fronteras y la guardia nacional y
juega un papel bastante importante en
todo el comité de defensa de Ucrania se
dice que iba esta mañana hacia una
posición en el frente de batalla para
los helicópteros en Ucrania debido a las
condiciones vuelan alturas bastante
bajas y esto habría provocado dice una
de las versiones que la hélice habría
chocado con trae el techo de una de las
edificaciones una guardería las afueras
de la ciudad de kiev la capital lo que
no solamente habría provocado la muerte
de las nueve personas que iban en el
helicóptero entre ellos el ministro de
algunas de las personas que trabajaban
con él sino también algunos niños y
personas que estaban en no solamente en
la guardería sino en edificios cercanos
sin embargo la cifra de los muertos está
todavía por confirmar se habla más de 37
heridos en la actualidad en una de las
tragedias más graves de las últimas
semanas días atrás el país estaba
absolutamente triste después de ese
ataque con misiles a esa edificación de
la ciudad de Nitro que había dejado más
de 44 personas fallecidos y O al menos
en el momento hay 20
desaparecidos sin embargo hoy vuelven a
despertarse con esta tragedia el
ministro del interior es la persona de
más alto Rango en el gobierno que ha
muerto desde que comenzó la invasión a
escala completa o es decir esta guerra
desde el 24 de febrero del año pasado el
gobierno dice que va a realizar una
investigación sobre cuál es realmente
serían las causas de esta tragedia